let's see if we can get a sense of
different masses and we're going to do
that by doing the arithmetic word
problems with mass on Khan Academy so it
says which is the closest to the mass of
a cow so it's either seven kilograms or
seven hundred kilograms so let's think
about what seven kilograms would be so
one kilogram if you're used to dealing
with pounds one kilogram is 2.2 pounds
so seven kilograms is like fifteen or
sixteen pounds that would be the weight
of maybe a large cat or a several month
old baby that would be seven kilograms
so most cows are not the size of just a
large cat they are much bigger than that
seven hundred kilograms that actually
seems a little bit more right that's
going to be closer to that's going to be
closer to 1,500 pounds cows are really
really big animals and they weigh a lot
so I would go with seven hundred
kilograms because seven kilograms is
just ridiculous that's the size of a of
a yeah as I've said a large cat let's
keep going
all of Glinda's magic wands have the
same mass Glinda knows the mass of one
magic wand what is the total mass of
seven magic wands so it tells us the
mass of one magic wand is six grams and
just so you know six grams is not a lot
so you might in the last video in the
last exercise we saw we were talking
about seven kilograms or 700 kilograms
when you put a Killough in front of gram
that means 1,000 grams so seven
kilograms is seven thousand grams here
we're just talking about straight-up
grams so grams are not much mass at all
if you were to think about a teaspoon of
sugar that's about four or five grams of
sugar so this wand is very very light
but anyway what they're asking us is
what would be the what the mass of seven
magic wands well if each of them are six
grams and we have seven of them seven
times 6 is 42 so we're going to have 42
42 grams
let's keep going this is fun all crayons
at Karen's crayon factory have the same
mass Karen weighs 7 crayons and find
that they have a total mass of 56 grams
what is the mass of one of the crayons
so 7 crayons have a mass of 56 grams so
the mass of each of them well let's just
take 56 and divide it by 7 by the 7
crayons
well 56 divided by 7 is 8 7 times 8 is
56 so the mass of each crayon is 8 grams
and you could even check that 7 crayons
times 8 grams per crayon is going to be
56 grams this is surprisingly fun Tina
has 5 pencils all of her pencils have
the same mass Tina finds the mass of one
pencil shown below
and it's 8 grams what is the total mass
of 5 pencils
well if one pencil is 8 grams 5 pencil
is going to be 5 times 8 grams well 5
times 8 is 40 it's going to be 40 40
grams all right this one seems similar
although Sophia is squirrel all of
Sophia's squirrels acorns have the same
mass Sophia squirrel finds the total
mass of our four acorn shown below what
is the mass of one of the acorns so here
actually this is a little different than
the last one they find the mass of all 4
or 4 acorns or 20 grams so what's the
mass of each of them well 4 times what
is 20 or 20 divided by 4 is what well 20
divided by 4 is 5 so 5 10 15 20 so if
each of them are 5 grams 5 grams times 4
is going to be going to have a mass of
20 grams